so I recently saw a film called
parasites which turned out not to be
about infectious agents of humans but
was actually a lot better and it was a
really great film directed by bong
joon-ho which totally deserved the Oscar
Awards but it led me to why I've never
heard of this director before or seen
any of his other films so being a
scientist the film that caught my eye
was octa a film about a super pig so
hello and welcome to Vichy he signs you
we're in this video we'll talk about all
the science behind it and genetically
modified organism so before I go any
further with the science I feel like I
should give you a gist of the film
hopefully without too many spoilers so
the form begins in 2007 where you get
introduced to Lucy Miranda the CEO of
the Miranda corporation and what Lucy
Miranda announces is that they've been
breeding a special kind of super pig and
what their plan is is they've got 26 of
these super pigs like culture and what
they want to do is give them to 26
different farmers across the globe and
then 10 years later though announce who
has the best super pig so one of these
two pigs get sent to a South Korean
farmer and with his granddaughter media
they raise one of the Siva pigs that
they call okra and after 10 years guess
what
ultra is the cloud the best super big so
why are they making these super pigs in
the first place well according to you
Lucy Miranda the super pigs will be big
and beautiful leave a minimal footprint
on the environment consume less feeds
and produce less excretions and most
importantly tastes really good
so being able to generate food that has
a minimal footprint on the environment
that would consume less feeds and have
less expressions you know reducing
methane co2 production will reduce the
effects of climate change are all really
important problems that we need to face
in the food industry and I guess the
idea of it being biggest to be more
meeting to provide more foods per animal
and I guess tasting good isn't really
that important but you know I think
that's in the film for that traumatic
effect so the film takes you back to
media he's been raising octa her entire
life and isoline freed film actor is
pretty pretty much raised by media and
they have this emotional connection
between them and ultra smart like you
see also save meter from falling off a
cliff and when I hear Animal Farm yeah
but I'm the princess is inevitably the
fate of vulture is to end up on
someone's dinner plate along with some
vegetables maybe and throw film shows
how all just taken away and media tries
to get off your back so sorry about
spoilers but going back to the Miranda's
idea about all these different factors
that are actually really important but
the front generally fixed was more about
Miranda being a corrupt company out to
get money and it isn't as much about the
science and the environmental impact
which is what with meaning to talk about
in this video so going back to the super
pixel how are they actually created well
according to the CEO of Miranda I took
nature and science and I synthesized
yeah that doesn't really leave you of
March so in the film they claim that
these super pigs are all-natural and GMO
free but that isn't the truth ads
there's no literal way that they could
have naturally produced these super pigs
but what actually are GMOs well they're
genetically modified organisms so to
give a better definition a genetically
modified organism is an organism say
appliance animal or microbe that has had
its genetic information modified and the
way that that's modified is using
genetic engineering approaches or
transgenic techniques and so you end up
with an organism that you couldn't
necessarily get just free selective
breeding so what did they actually do
then to generate a super pig such as
octor so in case you haven't seen the
film let's first try and describe what
these super pigs actually look like so
the super pig is kind of look like calf
eggs half Heco's half manatees I'm
pretty big and they're currently all
females and they have one nipple and
these ginormous eyes so I mean I think
that's a bit sci-fi honestly I don't
think you would ever be able to generate
something like Akhtar and even the
director themselves they they claim that
is meant to be realistic it just really
isn't it's more just to have a nice
loveable character for the film but
however they designs ultra they did it
for it to be a sustainable alternative
to the current meat options that are
available and say other things such as
implants you have like the Seas
resistance is also another quality I
would add to that list we saw earlier
but you know should we be using
genetically modified organisms because
it's a very controversial topic so why
have people against it well mainly
because they didn't think the food is
safe and continuing with that maybe they
don't really understand what a
genetically modified organism is there's
also issues with the regulation and how
its labeled because currently some
things they might be genetically
modified but they haven't got a label
saying that they are and that can cause
controversy as well but other arguments
against the use of GMOs isn't
necessarily related to the science but
more to do with the companies that are
just trying to make a profit such as you
see with the Morandi corporation in the
film dr. so what are the arguments for
the use of genetically modified
organisms then well one quote from
Roberts sake who is very current and
knowledgeable in this area
he said that to feed the world we would
have to grow 10,000 years worth of food
in the next 30 years
and going on that's basically there is a
huge food crisis at the moment and only
in the amount of lubricant generates but
making sure that what we do generate is
sustainable and done in an
environmentally friendly manner so you
know as I've already mentioned the idea
behind these modified organisms is to
reduce the impact that the crops and
organisms have on land use i'm co2
emissions which is all to try and reduce
the impacts of climate change whilst
feeding the world at the same time and
so yeah this goes back to what the mind
Incorporation were trying to do with
having a minimal footprint
consuming less feed and producing less
excretions so as I've really said I
don't think you would see a super pig
like doctor in the future but we can at
least evaluate if they achieve some of
these goals with regards to being
sustainable alternatives to meat so from
watching the film I didn't really know
how much Otto was eating but it seemed
like he was eating less feed and
definitely had some way it's kind of
excretion system but in terms of more
food production it took ten years to
raise doctor which actually means the
output in terms of meat production is
very low for these super pigs so yeah I
don't think auction would really be a
solution so other alternative
genetically modified organisms that
would be effective for sustainable food
production in the future well you may
have already heard about Golden Rice
which was developed she provides a
greater amount of vitamin A in the rice
and that was to try and prevent little
needs efficiency so actually this is a
bit different from trying to increase
crop growth rates but more what you can
do to improve the foods that you're
eating in the first place you kind of
get more like bang for your buck and so
I made a video before about these so
called potential superfoods this is a
very hypothetical idea that I made but
the idea is that if we can modify these
crops we can pretty much because be as
imaginative as we can be with what we
can optimize and improve and given that
you know the population is only gonna
grow and demand to feed is increasing I
think that's definitely why research
should be focused on because it's a
really important issue but another thing
you may have heard about our genetically
modified salmon such as IQ advantage so
this is a genetically modified salmon
that are produced by this company called
aqua bounty and Washee on their website
they claimed they're healthy and tasty
which [ __ ] is a bit like the Miranda
corporation they taste really good but
more and from that they are good for the
environment and for consumers and that's
Polly you know just the way that they
they can these these salmon may grow at
a much faster rate so you get a much
higher production of foods in a short
period of time which means that the use
of food
feed for the salmon is much lower and
you get a greater like turnover and um I
think it's really interesting what
they're doing and they received FDA
approval for that technology why they
basically gave they basically helped the
salmon with a growth hormone gene that
came from a different fish species which
means that they pretty much always
expressed this great hormone which is
why the grave rate is much higher but
they also said that people are against
the use of genetically modified
organisms so other alternatives to GMOs
so one thing that I think in terms of
the future food is we really need to be
able to reduce meat consumption and say
we can either go towards non meat
products or go towards meat that isn't
made from live organisms so to speak so
first let's look at reducing meat
consumption you may have heard of such
companies such as beyond meats and the
impossible in corporation but you've
heard of beyond meat burgers and the
impossible burger well basically they
produce meat products like burgers but
they're not meats in terms of and will
meet their plant-based meats but even
more interesting technology is being
developed whereby instead of doing
plant-based products you can still
create animal needs and I'm not pretty
but you use it from cultured meat so
this is like lab-based meat and so does
companies such as just and raised meats
that are trying to develop ways of being
able to achieve this so I thought like
this always gonna be people here are
against the use of these new
technologies either because they're
unnatural or they don't understand the
safety concerns associated with them but
under the day I think it's important to
remember that it's all about being able
to sustain our planet and I think that
is what these companies are trying to do
I mean sure there's profits as well but
they're trying to make food sustainable
and so hopefully this videos been make
it intro to the kind of current
understanding of GMOs and some potential
future options for foods so as always
thanks for listening